[laughing awkwardly] What a weird beginning for a video that's titled this.
Hi guys, my name is Grace Helbig. If you did not know, now you know and your life is different now
I could not think of a video idea that I wanted to post today, and I realized a lot of the reason I couldn't just
allow myself to think...
clearly was because I was feeling a little depressed, and spoiler alert this happens to me kind of frequently and as an adult I've talked to some
professionals and I can identify it and it's okay, and everything's fine
and it's normal but I thought, "Hey, why don't we just embrace this and make this the video?"
I've been managing my own
anxiety and whatever
feelings for years and years now, so I thought hey let's use this video as
a way to show you guys things I've learned over the years that helped me...
calm the bad
I like to engage in passive creative activities. For me that's cooking, but then I realize that I'm not cooking
I'm just using this activity to avoid my inbox and unanswered calls from family members and loved ones, and then I just--
Another tactic I use is watching reality television. I love it. I think it's so dumb and so fun, until I realize that perhaps
I'm using it as a tool to watch people that I subconsciously think are in deeper pain than I am and then I just--
Another major tactic is playing with my dog who gives me nothing but pure love energy
because she thinks that her job is just to love me and it's
absolutely amazing, until I realized that I voluntarily linked myself up with something I would likely outlive and then I just--
Sometimes I do my hair and makeup to feel better
and then I realize the fleeting side of vanity because my body is a vessel for my personality,
it doesn't actually represent who I am or what legacy I want to leave because it will decline rapidly and then I just--
Sometimes I like to read very intellectually inspiring books
that have been recommended on Instagram before I realize that the person that recommended this on Instagram and also myself are just
trying to seem cool by association rather than actually taking into thought any of the intellectual, inspiring material inside the book, and then I just--
Exercise is my number one go-to for any sort of anxiety that I am experiencing
until I realize that I'm alone with my thoughts, and what am I actually running from, metaphorically not physically? And then I just--
Well there you go. There are a few ways that
I manage my personal anxiety and depression. If you liked this video give it a thumbs up. Don't forget to subscribe to my YouTube channel
I make videos Monday, Wednesday, and Friday
infrequently... unless the demons in the head come out to play.
I don't know.
I think we got that one [snorting laugh].